You are listening to
radiolab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
Okay. From the top. You Ready? Yep.
Hello. How are you doing?
We're going to start things off
today with this lady, Zelda Gamson.
Come to our little spot
to beautiful. Thank you.
She's 80 years old and these days
Zelda lives a quiet life by the sea on
Martha's vineyard. Did you have some
coffee? She visits with her grandkids,
does some gardening.
We have a bird feeder and it
is the bird show of the world,
but life for though wasn't always so calm
back in the 60s when our story begins,
she was a very different kind of lady.
She even went by a different nickname,
just z.
Okay. I was a smoker 30 years.
I started when I went to college in 1954
first it was just a cigarette here or
there,
letting the bad girl out a bit and then
I got hooked really and I couldn't stop.
Went to graduate school, smoked,
got my dissertation, smoked,
got my degree, smoked in
somewhere in the fog. She meets.
Hi My friend Mary. Also
a smoker. Loves Smoking,
made me feel very elegant.
We were very good friends.
We were part in the year,
early sixties of the Congress
on racial equality together.
They'd organize protests.
We would demonstrate in the two of
them would even go under cover to fight
housing discrimination and the
backdrop to all of this social change.
Smoke. Yeah. You got it. I mean, our
houses were filled with these ashtray.
How much were you smoking at that
point? Probably smoked a packet of day.
I was aware smoker than Mary and I was
sometimes up to two packs a day. Wow.
You know, I had kids, I was pregnant,
um, while you were pregnant.
Guy Did. Wow. Yeah. I
feel so guilty about that.
So at a certain point, Zelda and Mary
decide they want to stop. Yeah. No.
Mary who had never been as badly
addicted to Zelda. It wasn't easy.
It was agonizing, but
eventually she's able to do it.
Zelda now I thought sometimes that I
could stop and so I would over and over,
she throw out her cigarettes.
Okay. Done. But then,
then I'd be around somebody
with cigarettes. Oh,
F any reason that you'd give
yourself cancer? My kids this smell,
the fact that I could die, you'd
always lost out to the urge.
And I'd always start smoking again.
And this is how we'd go resolve failure,
resolve failure. Okay?
So this is not the most
unusual situation in the world.
But the question you want to ask right
now is like, how do you get out of this?
You know, you want to do
something, they happily,
but then another part of you
says, no, I don't want to do that.
So if you against
you, what do you do?
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
and today I'm the little deals that you
make when you are stuck with yourself.
Okay? So before talking with Zelda,
just so happened that I had
went with Adam Davidson,
one of the planet money guys to visit, uh,
this fellow Nobel prize winning
economist named Thomas Shelling me.
You're the first to know who's written
a whole lot about the seemingly simple
idea of commitment,
arranging it so that you can't
compromise. I'll give you an example.
Here's the one from ancient Greece,
Xenophon, the Greek who, uh,
was being pursued by a
huge army of Persians,
had to make a stand on a hillside
and one of his generals said,
I don't think this is a good
location to make our stand.
There's a cliff behind this. There's
no way we can retreat if we need to.
And Xenophon told his general
exactly. Welcome the cliff. In fact,
he said, here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna March our armies so that
their backs are directly to the cliff.
That way the Persians will
know that we can never retreat.
We're bound to fight to the death.
You're really binding yourself.
You're not binding the other side. Yeah.
It's attempting to influence somebody
else's choice by restricting your own
choice. But then we asked him,
what if your adversary isn't on
the outside like the Persians,
but rather it was you. [inaudible] how
do you do with Xenophon? Did to yourself?
Yeah. I, uh, I began smoking
when I was 17 years old. I,
I did quit several times,
but I always say
I back. Ooh.
But he did tell. He did give us
some suggestions. One in particular,
there was so awesome to
use your favorite words.
So a diabolical yeah,
that we just didn't think
anyone would ever do it. Oh,
that is until we met Zelda. Yeah.
Fast forward a few decades,
1984 Marion Zelda now live in
different parts of the country.
I happened to be going to a conference
in Vermont and Mary picked me up at the
airport, right. And I was
smoking when she picked me up,
which was curious because
nobody smokes anymore. She said,
why Celta are you still
smoking? And Zelda said, yeah,
and don't tell me to stop.
I was very belligerent.
Yes.
So I went to the conference and smoked
and where they guilty cigarettes.
No, they were delicious.
But what Mary said was starting
to worm its way into her brain.
Are you still smoking? Still
Smoking, still smoking.
And when she dropped me off at
the airport, I said, okay, Mary,
as if she had been putting pressure
on me, which she wasn't at all.
If I ever smoke again,
I'm going to get $5,000
to the Ku Klux Klan.
What did she say? $5,000 to
the Klu Klux Klan, correct?
[inaudible]
this was shelling suggestion can work,
but he didn't think
anyone would ever do it.
$5,000 to the Ku Klux Klan. It
just came out of my math. Huh?
You know how horrible they are,
right? Sure. So heinous. But
her and Mary made a deal.
A pact. If Zelda smoked,
she'd have to tell Mary
to send the KKK her money,
take it out of my savings or
something. And you were really serious.
You were going to do this. Yeah,
but I have to say after I made this
pledge to marry under my breath,
I said, but I can't be
responsible if she smokes again.
What if she smokes again?
If she smokes again?
Who's the she in that sentence? Me You.
What does that mean? Well,
that means that a part of me,
the part of me that was smoking and
that might pick up smoking again was an
alien part. You're saying you are
two people at that moment? Yeah.
And she xe didn't really
want to stop smoking.
She, she, yeah.
After the pact, Zelda says that
often when she would fall asleep,
I would dream of myself smoking and she'd
wake up in a terrible sweat reach for
her cigarettes. But every time
she says this other thought,
we just rush into her mind.
The KKK robes, burning crosses,
lynchings, Gosh, she'd throw
the cigarettes down. I could.
The idea of them having her money,
I can't even imagine. It
sounds like you really backed
yourself up against the cliff.
I did.
Zelda had found a thought
that was hotter than the years
and she didn't smoke again.
Never again. Nope. That was it.
Cold Turkey.
Mm.
Look at this.
There's a picture of me on a cruise
that bill and I took your sheet. Yes.
It's a profile picture of
me. Look at the cigarette.
I [inaudible] gorgeous there. See,
that's the best picture ever taken of me.
[inaudible]
now if we are many people on the inside,
and we've talked about
this on the show before,
how like our brain is literally divided
into these camps that sometimes wrestle,
right, fight. Well, the problem,
I think the problem is
according to Thomas shelling,
is that these cells exist simultaneously.
We're never at the table together.
The one who's in charge
never confronts the other.
I guess that makes it hard to
compromise, although you know there
is another way to think about the problem.
Things that are offered right now have
so much more power than things that are
offered in the future. Oh,
this is David Eagleman.
He's a neuroscientist
and he says, you know,
really you could think about this
whole thing as a battle about time.
We'll make all sorts of very poor
economic decisions now versus leader if
something is offered right now versus
later. When you look at the neuroimaging,
it becomes clear that there are
different parts of the brain that are,
that are battling this out in the
now parts are waste. Trunker yes.
Here's the key. What she's doing in the
case of the cigarettes is she's saying,
I know that I want to
win this longterm battle,
but I'm having a heck of a time doing it.
But if I can make the longterm plan tied
into a different immediate feeling of
disgust, then all I have to do is have
the discussed battle, the the desire.
I see. So she's,
what she's done is she's turned this
battle into a present tense battle on both
sides. I want a cigarette now
versus I hate the KKK now.
Precisely. It's a now versus now thing.
And I think that's the only way we ever
win these longterm battles is to give
them some sort of emotional salients
some reason why they matter to us right
now. Otherwise it'll never work. And there
are any number of ways of doing this.
Here is how Thomas shelling did it,
1980 gather my children together and I
said I quit and that they should never
have respect for their father again. If I
returned to smoking any never. He
never did. And that was it for him.
[inaudible].
The thing I like about about those two
stories is that like there's the case
where like, okay, say you've got
these sales battling in your head,
you've got the now part in the later
part and the later parts week. Yeah.
In this case, the later part found
a way to trick the now parts,
and this has a name,
this kind of approach.
It's called the Ulysses contract in
the Elliot. Make that the out thing.
There's a moment where you list these in
as men have to sail past the island of
the sirens and you list these nos. If
they hear the siren song, they're dead.
Sailors were so attracted
to these melodies that they
would steer towards them
and crash their ships into the
rocks and die. So on his way there,
before the music started,
he came up with a plan.
He had his men lash him to the mast with
ropes so that he couldn't move and he
had them fill their own ears
with bees wax. And he said,
no matter what I do, no matter how,
I'm just sticky waiting or shouting
or acting like a crazy man,
just keep rowing. Just keep going.
And so when they got to the sirens
[inaudible]
Ulysses,
he goes nuts and he's screaming and
yelling and telling the men go towards the
women. We don't want to pass this up.
And of course the men have
bees wax in their ears.
They're not swayed by the siren song
because he had planned for this,
the present tense Ulysses,
by using his men and the rope had
literally bound the future to the
mast cause he knew that guy would be weak.
[inaudible]
we can just move off the ocean for just
a moment. Gun, get out of your ocean
radio. What a weird medium. Anyway,
what is the bargain that you strike isn't
just about something, you know, very,
very small. And now
like this puff of smoke,
what if it's a deal that you have to do
that will decide what you're going to do
for every day of the next
40 years? Yeah. What then?
Well, this brings us to a story from
our producer Pat Walters. Ready? Okay.
Set it up. Okay. Okay. I'm in
Chinatown. About a year ago,
a corner of Hell and ah, my friend
Jenny posted something on Twitter.
It said, overheard.
I flipped the coin and I lost my life.
[inaudible]
I flipped a coin and lost my life.
Yes. And what's Twitter? Yeah,
I mean she, she actually heard someone
say this? Yeah. She was just like,
she's a reporter.
She was just chatting with the guy and
he s and he said he said that to her.
I flipped the coin and I lost my
life. Wow. What was the context I,
while she was getting
a massage in Chinatown.
And how would that phrase come up
in the middle of a massage? I don't,
I honestly don't know. But she's a
reporter. Did she, did she ask you to say,
get your hands off me,
man, and tell me the story.
I don't know exactly what went down,
but I asked her what the situation was.
She said that she basically
didn't know anything,
but she just heard that she heard it and
she told me that it was at this place
that was like either at one of seven
different addresses that she gave me.
So I just wondered around,
do you know if some place around here
called health trail a massage place has no
idea. No.
Wandered around to several different
addresses and eventually I found this tiny
little storefront. It a little sign on
the feet kind of hidden.
Oh, you're one those [inaudible]
my son and a found the guy.
What that is. You said the thing,
hi. Hi. How are you? I'm okay.
His name is Dennis Dennis. And
you just asked him how you,
tell me about this coin flip. Can you
tell me, can you, so when did this happen?
How bout about four years ago?
I was 26 and my brother was uh, 21.
Both of them had gone to college, Dennis
for photography, his brother for art,
joy. And they come out of school
with these big dreams in new places,
meeting New People, making
a live and making money.
But that hadn't really worked
out. Yeah, I know Jeff for me,
they're having a hard time finding jobs
and they ended up living at home with
their dad. Yeah, with my dad.
So basically I just staying
home to picture and my brother,
he's just working at a
restaurant, low life eater.
So this is basically post-college
flail. Yeah. Like they're stuck.
Stuck in the middle of the road.
That's what happened to us.
And one day their dad comes up
to them and says, look guys,
one of you guys follow
me. I need one of you.
I don't care which one of you, but I
need one of you to take over the family.
My phone is getting all
this design I eat above you.
Come out or one of your [inaudible].
So one of them now has to carry on his,
his thing. Yeah. What is it that I
do here in this massage parlor? Yeah.
Since we're not interested. Yeah,
Nita was what really want to do it.
That's kind chi will Dennis's little
brother because touching people food,
it's some kind of disgusting. Right.
And there's always a hairy guy or
like some girls like busted toes.
Disgusting and annoying. Facing your
father for 24 hours. Seven days a week.
Yeah, a little more than I
can take. Like I love my dad,
but he just don't want to
follow your dad's footsteps,
but the dad says get over it. It's about
family, keeping the business alive,
keeping the technique he has
alive in the whole channel town.
I don't think any massage place or any
therapy place will have my father. To me,
it's a special kind of thing.
Yeah, it's this like deep tissue.
Acupressure is painful type massage.
I don't know. Have Jenny told you?
That is really painful. Anyhow,
they're sitting at home and this question
is kind of like silently hanging over
them for days and weeks till one day
that a friend's place having some tea,
talking about their dad and Dennis looks
up at his brother and says as make a
bet. Let's do the TV thing. The weather.
Let's see what the what the what
the TD say? Well, Dennis says,
when you're drinking loose
tea, the Chinese, right,
you put the leaves right in the bottom
of your cup and you pour the water over
them and usually the leaves float up to
the top flat on the surface of the team.
But every now and that every tank company
buys the tips is floating and the rest
of the body is inside of water.
So like the stem sort of? Yeah.
And then the leaf is hanging down. Yeah.
You mean like every so often instead of
the whole leaf being on the top of the
water or the leafy part just falls to the
bottom and just the tip of the stem is
touching the surface of the water.
Almost like it's hanging down from the
surface of the water. And this is rare.
Yeah. So when you get that estimate is
good luck. It is that like a traditional,
fun old people that was doing it. That's
how we understand it. And we was kid.
So we just decide, okay,
whoever, we get that,
whoever gets the most lucky
tea leaves, we didn't.
Well, when you're out, you don't
need to. My Dad, whoever lost,
follow my father foster, they trusted
their whole future to this. Yeah.
It was like the spur of the
moment thing. Why didn't we, yeah,
we didn't really plan anything
from pipe people to flip a coin.
Like they can't figure out which way
should they go. So this is flip a coin.
When you pull all the hot water in,
they will like rolling out loud
like a small tomato. Is it spinning?
And then once it's done,
each cup has a layer of tea leaves on
the surface and Dennis notices. So whoa,
look at it that he'd gotten one,
one piece that was like, wow.
As that incredible. Then you
looked over to his brother's cup.
Oh my God.
Way More of these lucky leaves.
It was pretty obvious. Yeah.
He lost and it wasn't even close. No.
Do you remember if he was like angry
or looks like he was deep in thought.
I don't think like, damn, this is
like as the worst thing in my life.
Uh,
and it basically was because now he was
bound by these tea leaves to go and work
for his dad.
What happened? Did you
first come here to work?
I don't feel like touching anybody
foot, so he forced me to touch the foot.
Did he have to like grab your
hand and go? It says sit down,
take off his shoes without
washing his feet. Okay.
That's kind of discussed to myself. Is
this telling me to try to work on that?
His Dad eventually said practice on
your friends. Oh, is that Oh god, no.
They still hate me right now for giving
them all the pain. When that was gone,
do you remember like what was going
through your head? Were you like,
what am I doing? Like did you feel
like you're on the wrong track? Well,
um, I don't know how to
explain. Here's the funny thing.
Dennis says that there came a point
up to a month, look on my a fit.
I don't feel disgusting anymore. I'd
feel kind of like it. He likes it.
Yeah. I don't know why. It's
just like making me, ah,
it seemed nice to work on people.
Um, I don't know how to explain.
I just stopped fall in love with
this job. Yeah. I don't know.
How's that happen? I just, I working
here seven days a week, save,
become part of my life, wake up
in the morning, come here, work,
go home, sleep, come in with. So
as those become part of my five in,
when I've got a day off,
I don't know what to do,
where to call and just staying home.
Let me come back over here
and work as what happened.
It's just that I think
that's how foreign love is.
You don't know has to happen when
it's happened. It just happened.
It was a good loss. I was
thinking, I left this job.
So it sounds like you made this deal
with fate and he just got lucky.
No, no. Kai has a slightly different
on the whole thing. Well, so if he had
one, would you have had to do it? No, no,
no, no, no.
Kai says the whole Tealeaf deal
was really just about Dennis.
I think at that point in the back
of his head, he wants to do it.
Just an excuse. I think he was just
looking for a sign. I'd have to ask him,
I guess. And when I did ask Dennis, he
didn't really agree with his brother.
Well, it's just a, how you say his own,
but he didn't entirely discrete either
because I wanted to do it just like this
kind of, I'm using my brother to
push me to work from right there.
That's what, what do you mean by that?
I don't think he wanted to make his own
decision. It might be better just for,
for my dad, but I don't want to face him.
So if my brother just pushed me, okay.
I'll be facing him as that
could be what happened
[inaudible]
so we just needed a push. All right.
Would you be thing to do?
No. You know, when you think about it,
why is that wimpy? Well, I mean, he did.
He wanted to be a Missoula, you know,
and he didn't know what he wanted. Yo,
he knew and he set up his brother
to make him do it. So it's very, no,
if you call it wimpy and call it Wimpy,
I call it a powerfully
wimpy, muscularly wimpy.
Meaning what? What does that mean?
Meaning that, oh, I got one for you.
I'm going to lay this. You ready for this?
Maybe the new strength is
understanding your own wind penis.
What do you think about that? Ooh,
I just thought I just tied you into a
philosophical, not right there, buddy.
You're going to be thinking about that
one for years. I'm thinking about it.
I'm over thinking about it
in take it in the complexity.
Can I speak now? Yeah. David's going
to say something. This is who we are.
I mean that's the reality on
the ground. We're just weak.
We need help and I
actually think this gives,
this gives us a new way to think
about and understand virtue.
I think it gives us a much
richer view of human nature.
Thanks to Pat Walters, our
Chinatown correspondent,
and to Thomas Shelling who's written many,
many books including the strategy of
conflict and to Adam Davidson from the
amazing planet money team and to David
Eagleman whose latest book is incognito.
We'll be right back.
Hey guys, it's David Eagleman radio lab
is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan
Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
Hi,
this is Yolanda Gamson calling more
information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
Radiolab is produced by w n
y c and distributed by NPR.
And this message.
Hey, I'm Jen [inaudible]. I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
And today today we are trying to figure
out how to make a deal with yourself
when most of you doesn't want to do
what the rest of you wants to do. Right?
And we've talked about these kinds of
deals when it comes to avoiding the
sirens, quitting smoking, figuring out
what to do with the balance of your life.
Now we're going to change things a bit.
Let's say instead of being an addict,
let's say you're just a writer. Yeah.
And you want to be inspired.
You want the words to come.
And this is very typical
situation. They're not coming. No.
No words to the question is
in that kind of situation,
what kind of deals could you make
with yourself to get the words out?
This is, uh, this is fanciful.
My friend Oliver Sacks,
the neurologist and the
writer, um, he made a deal,
which frankly find this kind of
astonishing [inaudible] bargaining
with creativity. I will tell you,
although I probably shouldn't, uh,
the first book I wrote, Migraine,
um, was very obstructed.
And then by obstructed he means he
just got stuck. Yes. Day after day, he,
she tried to write something down and
it just didn't come and I was getting
desperate on the matter.
And finally on September
the first of 1968,
I said to myself, you have
10 days to write this book.
If it is not done, then
you commit suicide. Whoa.
And under the
imagined threat,
which seem to tell the me
in a way because you're,
you're what the other half of you thought
that the first half of you meant it.
Yes. Did the first half of
you mean it? I don't know.
Right. But the result of this
was that after months of,
of stewing and not doing
anything, I started work.
And what started as a,
as a fearful task soon became a
joyful task with this own momentum.
And suddenly he had this feeling
that there was something inside him.
Some engine inside me, a
wonderful associative engine,
which we've sourced together,
brings unexpected things into acquisition.
It had kicked into gear and just kind
of pulling things out of him and putting
them right there onto the page.
I felt the book was being
dictated to me healing. Uh, I, I,
I was passive. I was the bridge.
I was the transmitter. Um,
and in fact I finished
the book a day early.
That's a strange way to kick yourself
in the pants. I have to say, yeah,
well I'm,
for me a deadline sometimes is
felt homeless literally as such.
This is not an easy way
to go to work every day.
I wouldn't think
[inaudible] can make bank.
And it's like that definitely not too
often. And it will have a cost. Oliver,
of course, did that only once, but
the story he told got us thinking,
is there a bargain that you can make
with yourself, your creative self?
It's somehow avoids this
terrible cost. Yeah.
That as long as this led me
generally in front of you late. Okay.
A woman who just does it differently.
I have this fascination with trying to
figure out how you can live a lifetime of
creativity without cutting your ear
off. You know what I mean? And who is,
who is that? Oh, I'm Liz Gilbert and
well just something a little bit now.
Which Liz Gilbert, you,
I'm the Liz Gilbert who wrote
the book called the pray love.
I guess that's the way she described
myself cause that's how my obituary will
read, eat, pray,
love in case you were born under her rock
or raised by wolves is one of the most
popular books ever,
ever, ever in the world.
It became even more popular when the
book became a, and guess who played Liz?
Liz Gilbert is remarkable. Julio Roberts,
her courage and the way America's
sweetheart and the success was great,
but she says, you know,
it was also kind of frightening because
there she was back at home under the
same old blank page with a new question.
How will you ever outdo
what you did last time?
Suddenly she's back where
Oliver was obstructive.
She didn't think that that success
was going to be there the last time.
So was the last time of fluke. Do
I even have another big book in me?
Dangerous Recipe for madness madness.
But then she thought back to a
conversation that she once had with,
nope.
Who Tom Waits. Tom Tom,
wait, that's sort of [inaudible]
where this all began was that I was,
I was a journalist for GQ and I did an
interview with him and he spoke about the
creative process I think more articulately
than anybody I have ever heard. Um,
and he was talking about how every song
has a distinctive identity that it comes
into the world with and it needs to be
taken in different ways. And he said,
you know, there are songs that,
that you have to sneak up on,
like you're hunting for a rare bird
and there are songs that come fully
intact, like a dream taken through a straw
[inaudible]
and there are songs that you find little
bits of like pieces of gum underneath
the desk and you scrape them off and
you put them together and you make
something out of it. And there are
songs he said that need to be bullied,
um,
where he said he's been in the studio
working on a song and the whole album is
done and this one song won't give
itself over. And he said, you know,
everyone's gotten used to
seeing him do things like this.
He'll march up and down the studio
talking to the songs, saying
the rest of their families in the
car, we're not going on vacation.
You coming along or not,
you got 10 minutes or else
you're getting left behind,
you know, and he's like, you gotta
shake it down. Sometimes lists as that.
The interview was maybe the first time she
thought of inspiration as, as, as an it.
And I remember feeling my own center
of gravity shift and thinking, wait,
you're allowed to talk to this thing.
That the source of her ideas was outsider.
That she could get some distance
from it, maybe negotiate with it,
even fight with it instead of beating
yourself up all the time. Right.
And this story that I loved,
that he told me about where his artistic
anxiety ended and his sort of new
artistic liberation began as when he's
driving along the freeway in Los Angeles
and like eight lanes of traffic one day.
And this little fragment of a
beautiful song comes into his head
[inaudible]
and he has no way to record
it. He's gotten no pencil,
he's got no tape recorder and he's
in eight lanes of stressful trap.
So come [inaudible].
And he immediately starts to feel all
the old pressure that he's felt his whole
life of, I'm not good enough. You know,
all the artistic struggle, right? I,
I can't do it. I'm not good
enough. I'm lose it. I, it'll haunt
me forever. And then he
just backed off from it.
And instead he established
that negotiating distance
between him and the melody.
And he looked up at the
sky and he said, excuse me,
can you not see that I'm driving if
you're serious about wanting to exist,
I spend eight hours a day in the studio.
You're welcome to come and visit
me while I'm sitting at the piano.
Otherwise leave me alone and
go bother Leonard Cohen. Oh,
that's very bold. It is. I
think that's what she wants.
She wants you to push back and she
wants you to set some terms and some
boundaries.
She doesn't want you to go to the
Leonard Cohen Concert two years later and
very, very kind of you to come to this.
Now,
this idea that somehow the creative
act comes from outside you.
You get a visit from a somebody,
this isn't the new idea.
This is a very old idea. You know
the Greeks would call it the Muse
[inaudible].
The Romans called it
the ingenium the genius,
which was an interesting idea because
it's not the way we use genius today.
Right?
Today we say that a person is a genius
and back then they would've said a person
had one. Um, and again it's
the separation so that the,
the creative person has this
externalized collaborator.
So this is a tinker belly kind
of a thing. It sprinkles you.
It has little wings. And I
think it depends. I think
it depends on the process.
I mean it's got a lot of names
because it takes a lot of forms,
right? And,
and we're talking about all this as though
these are actually kind of believe it
cause I don't think it
would work otherwise.
But I kind of do believe that the world
is being constantly circled as though by
Gulf stream forces ideas and creativity
that want to be made manifest and
they're looking for portals
to come through and people,
and if you don't do it,
they'll go find someone
else, you know? And,
and so you have to convince it that
you're serious and you have to show it
respect and you have to talk to it
and let it know that you're there.
Like for the last few years,
there's been a novel that has been sort
of stirring in me and I haven't had time
to give it the attention
it wants me to give it.
But every day I talk to it and I have a
little conversation with it and I say,
listen, I'm in April, I will be
with you. I want you to stay.
Don't let me wake up and read in the New
York Times that someone else wrote you.
Um, stay here with me. I'm
coming. This feels like this,
like a golden retriever or something.
You have to keep petting it. Actually,
that's probably as good a metaphor for
me as any because I would relate to that
being half golden retriever myself
and, and liking dogs. That's great.
And when you say you talk to it
and it's golden retriever reform,
that's our producer pat Walters. Like,
do you actually talk to it? Yeah,
I do. I talk.
That's why I have to work alone in a
quiet room because I talk to it all the
time and I ask you questions. I say,
what do you, what is it that you want me?
What do you want me to be doing here?
Because you seem to be to what I'm
trying to do here. Like show me,
give me a clue. Um, like
I, uh, the title of eat,
Pray Love was the last thing
that came of that book.
And the book was about
to be published in it,
had any number of ridiculous stupid
titles that I'm going to tell you cause
they're so embarrassing and they're
so not what that book was meant to be
titled.
And I ended up writing an email to all
my friends and saying the subject heading
was title search. And I said, my book
won't tell me its name and can you,
can all of you help me? And a friend
of mine wrote back and said, um,
if you're going to talk to it like that,
it's not going to tell you anything.
Um, so I really did that night,
talked to and sweetheart, listen,
I respect you, I love you.
I honor you. I have defended
you these last few years.
I want to bring you into the world,
but you have to tell me
your name and the next day,
eat, pray, love.
Oh, and you know it because it's,
I know the difference between something
I thought of and something that I was
given. I can, I can tell the difference.
She says sometimes it's the whole
scene. Sometimes it's just a word,
maybe a phrase. And then you have
the job to make it into something.
Wait. But if I,
if I say to you, [inaudible]
any yellow water,
so you can write that down. Two
roads diverged in the yellow one,
then you're done. Do you know
how that phone got written? No.
So he was working for, I may be
exaggerating this cause I tend to,
but I'm going to tell it
my way. How I heard it. Uh,
he was working for months
and months and months on,
on what was going to be the
greatest epic poem of his life.
It was the biggest challenge
that he was taking on.
He was going to be up
there with the masters,
with this [inaudible] named the
prison. We talking about. Yes,
this would be Mr. Frost. And, um,
and, and, and he worked on it for, um,
you know, forever and ever. I mean,
perspiration, perspiration, perspiration.
Right. And it was 20, 30 pages long and
it was, I don't know what the meter was,
whatever it was. It was the most
ambitious thing he'd ever done.
And it was arduous and it probably had
sweat all over it. Um, put it down,
went to sleep, woke up,
sat down and wrote two,
two roads and all of a sudden in
one setting, this tiny, perfect,
immaculate thing was created that had
nothing to do with what he had just done.
He earned it.
I think the angels reward people who
are at their desk at six o'clock in the
morning working right. And
he earned it by showing his,
his intent to be a great poet.
And they said, okay, cool.
You showed your intent, that
thing you just wrote with crap,
I'm going to give you this
one, here's your reward. So
except for that, it's a great story.
And I liked the idea and I feel like,
I really do feel like when they see
me working, they take pity on me. Um,
and they say, you look, you're
showing a real commitment to this.
You've been up at five o'clock every
morning for the last year working on this
novel. I'm just going to give you
the ending, you know, um, or I'm,
I'm going to spare you from that really
bad idea. You just having, you know,
I always think of it as like Henry Ford's
famous line about how creativity is
99% perspiration and 1% inspiration,
which is a very mechanical
way to divide it up.
But it also assumes that those
two things have equal weight,
that they're the same quality.
Right. I agree with 99% perspiration,
1% inspiration, but
it's 99% oyster 1% Pearl
[inaudible]
you can't even compare the,
the matter like it's a
bargain to get 1% inspiration.
You know, it's, it's a miracle.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I could get with the muses
sort of. What do you mean?
Well, I think it's interesting that you
can hear at one point she says that she
believes, I actually kind of
believe in another point she says,
it just makes a good
story. It's a great story.
And I like the idea so you can
hear her negotiating with the idea.
Yeah, of course. She's a little
bit between the two thoughts,
which is interesting. I
mean, you know, you know,
a serious neuroscientists would tell you
that it's all in your unconscious and
it's all, all you all the time. But
another way to think of it is, uh,
is to say that you got a gift and,
and therefore it's not all about you.
When it's bad and it's still
about you when it's good,
but it's not all about you. It's
just this business of all. Okay.
This is a form of well organized
and modesty. It's a nice phrase.
I'm just going to, it's
going to go with that. Yay.
It's time for us in our
ferries to go to break.
This is drew Lewis from Salt Lake City.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information about
Sloan had www dot Sloan
[inaudible].
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab.
Today we are continuing our search
for ways to outside oneself,
solve the problems going on
inside oneself. Ooh, nicely done.
Now thinking back to Oliver Sacks,
the story that we heard at
the top of the last segment,
[inaudible] this notion that
you, one might use terror to, uh,
to broker a relationship with one's
creative self or one's perhaps addicted
self. Let's take that idea and kick
it up a notch. All right, let's see.
Two notches. Oh, I mean for that we
go to the reporter, Gregory Warner,
reporter with marketplace
though marketplace was nice
enough to let us borrow
him for this story. He's
a budget [inaudible] right
now. You understand that?
I have no idea. Gregory. None. Whatever.
What is you're about to tell me? I am.
I have been purposely in the dark.
Yes. Unless of course you have
already told me somewhere. No,
I'm sure you've forgotten
that. So Greg, just set it up.
How did you find out about this? I heard
about it, um, while washing dishes.
Actually,
my wife was telling me about a friend's
ex boyfriend who was an alcoholic
friend's ex boyfriend. Friend's ex
boyfriend is an alcoholic in Russia. He's,
he's, he's Russian. And um,
this man didn't want to drink anymore.
And so the treatment that he got was to
have a capsule surgically inserted under
the skin. Some kind of chemical
compound that if he drank again,
this capsule would explode into
his bloodstream and kill him.
What wish he was given the bomb? Yeah,
that would be triggered by his bed.
Behave. Exactly. And that's all
you know. That's all I knew. Well,
but wait a second. Who would, who
would do this? Who, who did he go to?
Well that's, that's what I,
fortunately I was on my way to Russia.
And what was the question in your
mind was what's this real check check?
So I get to Moscow and I
hired a fixer interpreter.
Her name is [inaudible]. It's hard
to tell what street I'm on right now.
She had found this clinic
that does this treatment.
We go in through the gate, call this area,
lungs of Moscow, the lungs of Moscow,
because the wind is coming through this
area and we arrive at this sort of large
house, kind of a drab exterior.
They usher us immediately
into a waiting room.
[inaudible] there's a fish tank.
It's their plants. Pretty Lush.
So it wasn't very hospitaly. No, not
very hospitaly very, very comfortable.
Guys are really lazy fish.
And then there's your question
where summit, hi, my name is so head
doctor, his name, slow, very slow,
yet just slow Davita. He greets us. We
become into his pretty spare office.
It's been described vouchers love.
He looks actually exactly as you'd
guess a a Russian psychotherapists and
oncologist. But look, I
have no guessing for that.
Maybe I take that back. He's got a point
t beard and he's got a bulbous head,
bright, bright green eyes.
And this man is a doctor and
this man is absolutely a doctor,
no of which there are degrees on the wall.
She was a [inaudible].
Usually this capsule is inserted
into the buttocks as well.
It therapy actually is. That's
why it was cold at torpedo
because it is placed in a person's body
and kept the way a torpedo and assemble
marine is kept in your
butt or under the skin.
And if the person drinks,
does it make them sick
or does it make them die?
[inaudible] he said, you know, it
doesn't, no [inaudible] kill you.
One can never exclude death,
but of course the doctor is
not going to kill his patient.
Which employee but personal feel.
It's very bad, extremely bad.
So still to know you will have
a type pains, almost unbearable.
[inaudible] accelerated
heart rate less than an hour.
And the shortness of breath, everything.
Nausea, vomiting, throbbing headache,
visual disturbance,
mental confusion come pre
and circulatory collapse.
And these medicines can remain in the
body from a short period of time, two,
three years for instance.
But the pill is real well,
so that's exactly what I asked them next
is the capsule in some way a placebo
yet it's not a placebo, placebo,
vpg and [inaudible] if he don't believe
I can give you a pill and that will be
like coding for one day. Okay.
Wait a new freaking pair. I would, um,
can you give me a pill that
would last um, three years
[inaudible] at least with this
[inaudible] if you agree, drag rate,
what the phrasing.
I'll tell you what I was thinking because
at this point I have it off and I had
been talking for like two hours and
he hadn't let me out of the office.
I had asked to see the procedure room.
I had asked to see the torpedo until I
realized the only way to actually see it
was to agree to have it done.
[inaudible] a patient. Yeah.
You were ready. Yeah. Let's
go. We leave the office,
we go down a hallway and up some stairs.
There's no lush carpet,
no fish tanks, no plants.
That someone's screaming. Yeah. Ah,
it's a psychiatric clinic. Meanwhile,
my translator is getting worried.
She's like, you know, if
you meet a friend in Russia,
you have to go drinking with
them. I said, I'll die. And
so he leads me into this room.
It looks just like an exam
room in a doctor's clinic.
There's this sink in the nurse heart
defibrillator machine. You can,
I see the, uh, and he just
immediately ignores me,
kinda picks up some instruments,
washes his hands. I see the torpedo.
He then turns and he says,
yes, there is a cart.
He does a stabbing motion with his
foot, his hand. This is how deep it is.
[inaudible] so he's going in? Yes.
Just before he's going to
actually cut open my butt.
And he does this with everybody. He
gives you a pill, which is the same drug,
but it only lasts for one day.
And then he tests it. He tests it.
How does that work? Can you take a
pill and he'll give you a drop of
[inaudible] as he puts
just a drop of vodka.
Small job of on your towel drop off.
Once that drop of Baka hits my tongue,
I will feel all those
symptoms. You had sinks.
You can't pre in January a
personal pills. He's telling you
[inaudible] sometimes people are
so scared that urinate right here.
Maybe a, uh, can I take it at home?
How much of the [inaudible]
so I, uh, actually no,
I don't want to take care of it.
Chicken dog can't do it. I'm not,
I'm not strong enough.
He at that point realized he had
one w and he shows me the pillow.
This is what is inserted in
the body. Really. This is it.
It's so little little
mm about the size of a,
uh, a tech Tech Tech Tech.
Okay. The Ticketek torpedo,
it comes right off the lips.
It turns out that inside that
little pill is a very real drug.
It's called [inaudible] and it was, oh,
it was actually a substance that
was used in the rubber industry.
This is Eugene, Eugene Reichel.
I'm an assistant professor
at the University of Chicago.
He's writing a whole book about
these treatment programs in Russia.
He says this drug was discovered back
in the early 19 hundreds and they found
that the a workers in the rubber industry
were unable to tolerate, um, alcohol.
This is kind of folk knowledge in that
in the industry for awhile it was like,
don't give that guy a beer. He
works in rubber. I know I'm in bay.
Basically what they sell fram does is
it creates a kind of toxic byproduct.
They still for in blocks a certain enzyme
from being absorbed and it causes all
these very real symptoms. So you'd
get a little bit poison. Yeah.
And is this used outside of these
Russian clinics? It is, but,
but there is a big difference only in in
Russian clinics do they have these long
acting capsules, long acting form
of diesel for Ram, which is not
something that exists. The
subdermal implants basically,
they don't actually release any
dice slow fram after, you know,
the first week or something like that.
So, so if I had taken
that drop of alcohol,
then I would have felt all those symptoms,
but it doesn't last
for longer than a week.
Yeah. So effectively
that's basically a scam.
I believe scam is the
word you're looking for.
Mainstream is this, I mean,
is this the equivalent of like guava
pills or whatever they are where you can
find them in like vitamin shops,
but they're kind of fringy.
That's the thing is that is not
fringy at all. You know,
over 60% of the treatment methods offered
by Russian Nikon narcolic six zero 60
like more than half. Yes. Yes.
And Eugene emailed later to say
he was just being conservative.
The real number is closer to 80%
mm. Wow. Coded,
which happened 15 years before
he died. My own translator,
honor her uncle went through this
procedure when he, when he was drunk,
he didn't care before.
I remember my grandmother crying all the
time because you could go fishing and
then disappear for a night. And
this guy, textbook alcoholic,
everybody knew that he was drunk. He
went through this coding procedure.
It's called coding because it wasn't
the drug form that goes in your bud.
It was actually a a,
it's a kind of hypnotic suggestion
that goes into your brain. But,
but same general procedure
doctrine, the white go,
he was doing something
with his hands, some,
some gestures in front
of [inaudible] face.
And then he Sergei closed his
eyes and he had a feeling that,
uh, some wicked, uh,
force was pulled out of his body.
Had this guy finished high school. This
guy was an aeronautical engineer. Oh.
My sense is that,
that there's some people who suspend
their disbelief because at some level they
have the motivation to do that.
But if it only lasts a week,
why wouldn't people like after two weeks
or a month or six months, just start,
just take it sip and realize, oh,
nothing happened and they just start
drinking again. Cause some people do.
Some people do. First of all,
there are lots of people who do go to 12
step therapy and who Google could do go
60% 60% you said that 80% no,
no, no, no. I know, I know it's,
it is very prevalent and very
popular. So no, there's to this story.
We thought there's something
Russian about this. Yeah,
I know that it's got a sense
of submission and belief,
all sort of asserted by a higher authority
with no way to check or to second
guess ev.
Even the way in which we're repression
is used instead of acceptance.
It just feels very rushed and
wouldn't work in Manhattan,
wouldn't work in Los Angeles,
wouldn't work in Chicago.
But I think that here's the
distinction in North America,
the prevailing understanding of addiction
is that it's a disease of denial.
It's not about the substance as much as
it is about the fact that you're kind of
out of touch with some kind of truths
about your self in your condition.
That's a radically different
understanding of what the problem is. Um,
then the one that underlies the Saturday
interrupt as a skeptical American,
I got to say there is
something about this treatment,
this Russian treatment
that makes sense to me.
Seems to me when you're in
the grips of an addiction,
you've already lost control of a certain
part of yourself or a part of yourself
as already in control that shouldn't be.
And you can try and kind of love that
part and make peace with it and hug it and
do the 12 step thing. Or you can
destroy it, you know,
build a wall around it so that
you don't have to deal with it.
That's what [inaudible] is so good
at imprisoning that part of you.
[inaudible] religious [inaudible] skeptic.
Do you know what a panic
attacks of panic are?
[inaudible] struck? Struck is
fear. Fear. There is strong fear.
Do you understand what it
is? Strong, very strong fear.
This is when [inaudible].
Dr. David have told me that he had
trained as a psychotherapist during the
Soviet war in Afghanistan in the 80s he
says to me as to where we just imagine a
situation where a soldier
sees his friend on the road.
He has mines c tied to his
body. He has no ears, no eyes.
His legs are cut. It will be his
look normal, but he's still alive.
According to all rules, this kind of
person should be taken to the hospital,
but after seeing this, every
soldier says to his friend,
if you find me in this kind of condition,
tortured by the Mujahideen Godly kill me,
just watching go to these tortures
yesterday, we mean you can
drive a person crazy beatitudes.
Is that just something he
was having you imagine?
Are you saying that's something
he saw? That's something he saw.
Would he learn from the way in which
these mujahideen were fighting?
This war is that you can,
you can kill your enemy.
That's one method of warfare.
Or you can strike fear
into the heart of your enemy
and kill not only that soldier,
but terrorize his whole Putin a stolen
[inaudible] and what rules this world's
through fear.
If he could make you afraid
he could change here,
this coding, it completely
changed his life.
This is her uncle. Yeah.
He became very, uh,
I had a feeling that he sort of
discovered the life for himself.
Once again, he started gardening.
He started picking mushrooms.
Do you think coding worked?
I guess? Yeah. I don't know how it worked,
but it did work for him because he
hadn't drank the rest of his life.
[inaudible]
thanks Greg. All right, thanks.
Okay, I got to see that.
That right there, that's a Ulysses
contract, except for instead of the rope,
he got fear.
Right. As opposed to say if a
[inaudible] went through, um,
went through, you know,
counseling about the,
the sirens and it's not
necessarily, you know, in fact,
the sirens aren't that hot. In fact,
you'll die. Uh, yeah. And they, you know,
you really have a wife and
she's nice too. Anyhow,
thanks to mark blaze for
letting US borrow. Greg.
Greg has a great series he's putting
together on, uh, what is it? Yeah.
A series of stories on marketplace
about the economics of healthcare and in
Russia,
which you can get to from marketplace.org
or also radiolab.org and if you go
there, you can subscribe to our
podcast even wildly. Ulysses, his wife,
Penelope, just signed up the other week.
Try that little open. [inaudible]
I'm Jad I boom, rod. I remember probably,
thanks for listening.